l'adieu du triple d'angleterre à sa
princesse la foule et elle a recueilli
ce monsieur pour rendre un dernier
hommage à lady diana
d'abord sur le parcours jusqu'à l'abbaye
de westminster puis tout au long du
trajet qui devait l'amener à sa dernière
demeure
une petite prime sur un lac à près de
son village
dalton voilà monsieur bonsoir nous
allons revenir dans un instant sur ses
obsèques simple et émouvante
puis nous parlerons des autres titres de
l'actualité l'émotion en inde après la
mort de mère teresa
le nouveau massacre en algérie dans un
faubourg de la capitale
le voyage de jacques chirac en
mauritanie et la mort d'un grand chef
georg solti d'abord ses obsèques
exceptionnelle de retenue et de sobriété
avec leurs instants d'émotion comme
l'intervention du frère de diana ou bien
l'interprétation par elton john de sa
célèbre chanson candle in the wind dont
il avait réécrit les paroles pour
l'occasion
que par mail ou à laisser
on a tu vois tu
news tout près des besoins
mais nous ferons
bravo
quel est dévoué
on a vu aujourd'hui la famille royale à
l'unisson de son peuple elle qui avaient
tant tardé à prendre en compte l'
immense émotion populaire qu'a suscité
la mort de la princesse de galles bruno
le dreff
à cet instant londres retient son
souffle
les gardes gallois qui avait accompagné
la dépouille de leur princesse ont pris
son cercueil sur leurs épaules et ont
pénétré de leur talent dans l'abbaye de
westminster où furent célébrées ses
obsèques
une cérémonie suivie par un million et
demi de spectateurs est dit on plus de
deux milliards de téléspectateurs
une cérémonie où se mêlent est le
protocole le plus rigide et la ferveur
la plus populaire qui soit cercueil
recouvert d'un drapeau armes royales sur
un affûts de canon pour le protocole
cris et pleurs de la foule pour une
présence populaire jamais vu
et comme son peuple la reine accompagnée
d'une partie de la famille royale est
descendue dans la rue pour rendre
hommage à la princesse de galles
une princesse que la reine avait
dépouillé de son titre d'altesse royale
et pousser ou divorce l'an dernier mais
aujourd'hui la reine s'est incliné
devant elle
mais aujourd'hui pour la première fois
dans l'histoire la reine a fait mettre
le drapeau britannique en berne sur son
château de buckingham et le peuple
anglais a applaudi et le peuple anglais
a versé une larme de plus lorsque
william et harry des enfants de diana
accompagnés de leur père se sont jointes
au cortège
à leurs côtés charles spencer le frère
de diana et le prince philip époux de la
reine
une démarche non prévues au protocole
mais qui pourrait bien marquer le début
d'une réconciliation entre les
britanniques et leur monarchie
devant ces trois hommes et ses deux
enfants
le cercueil de la princesse de galles
couvert de fleurs blanches et ce bouquet
avec ce simple mot nomi maman derrière
500 représentants d'associations
humanitaires auxquelles la princesse de
galles consacré une partie de son temps
pendant que le cortège parcourait 5 km à
travers londres l'abbaye de wesminster
accueillait les 1900 invités des
familles spencer et windsor la
reine-mère 97 ans et son petit fils
édouard
la mère de lady diana et sa famille
monsieur mohamed al fayed le père de
dodi
le premier ministre britannique tony
blair
et puis des célébrités amis de diana du
chanteur elton john et george michael
le ténor luciano pavarotti à la demande
de la famille de lady diana la
télévision britannique qui
retransmettaient la cérémonie ne réalise
à aucun groupe landais diverses
personnalités présentes
c'est le frère de diana qui lui rendit
hommage
un hommage en forme de défi à la presse
et de critique ou protocole royal elle
parlait sans cesse de fuir l'angleterre
en raison du traitement que lui ont
infligé les journaux
elle n'a jamais compris pourquoi ces
authentiques bonnes intentions étaient
tournés en dérision par les médias
pourquoi ils semblaient chercher sa mère
dans permanent in satin
c'est effarant ma seule et unique
explication est que l'autre entier une
bonté est considéré comme une menace à
l'extrémité opposée du spectre moral
nous respectons pleinement l'héritage
dans lequel tu es enfants sont nés et
nous respecteront toujours leur rôle
royal nous les y encourage on est comme
toi
nous voulons qu'ils fassent l'expérience
des moindres aspects de la vie pour
qu'ils s'arment spirituellement et
émotionnellement pour les années à venir
mais à la fin de son hommage l'émotion
est trop forte
la voix de charles spencer se brisent
des paroles que les 1900 invités de la
cérémonie et les centaines de milliers
de personnes qui la suivait à
l'extérieur applaudissent longuement le
cercueil de la princesse de galles prend
ensuite la direction du village où elle
sera enterrée et c'est alors que les
caméras britannique nous livre cette
image le prince charles et ses deux fils
c'est unique moment d'intimité et de
tendresse
alors daniel bilalian bonsoir vous avez
assisté ce matin à la cérémonie on avait
presque l'impression d'assister à la
naissance d'un mythe ou en tout cas à
quelque chose qui était inimaginable il
ya à peine quelques jours effectivement
venons avant-soirée naissance d'un mythe
ça c'est l'histoire qui nous le dira
mais nous avions vraiment l'impression
aujourd'hui le sentiment d'assister non
pas un événement de l'actualité mais
déjà un événement historique le maître
mot de cette journée tel que nous
l'avons ressenti si ces émotions
émotions jusque dans la famille royale
obligés pratiquement de descendre dans
la rue au niveau du peuple anglais
émotions très réelle de ce peuple
anglais qui s'étaient rendus en masse
sur le tracé du cortège pour terme signé
de son amour pour diana
bien sûr diana et le peuple anglais
avait eu quelques anicroches par le
passé on lui reprochait ses fredaines
c'est bonaventure mais tout cela était
oublié aujourd'hui ce qui restait
c'était cette princesse moderne cette
princesse des coeurs comme l'a appelé le
premier ministre britannique
émotion bien réelle que nous avons
ressorti lorsque nos équipes ont
parcouru ce matin pendant la durée des
cérémonies les différentes allées de
buckingham palace où s'étaient réunis la
foule
reportage de bernard lebrun philippe
deslandes et jacques garnich après
l'océan de fleurs la marée humaine celle
justement des porteurs de bouquets qui
depuis huit jours à temps aux marches du
palais pour un adieu à leur diana dame
matinaux silencieux il occupe le
parcours
pour les derniers arrivés la vue sur la
rue ça donne ça mais on accepte sans se
plaindre en silence certains hésitent
sont perdus ou cherchent sur le plan la
meilleure place parmi les trois
kilomètres de la procession
impressionnant la nation réuni
britannique du commonwealth anglais de
la jamaïque ou des indes asiatiques et
musulmans écossais ou anglais ils sont
tous là ensemble dans un rare moment
d'unanimité perchée ou non quant au loin
résonne sur le goudron le pas des
chevaux c'est l'union nationale on se
sert pour immortels de la scène est
saluée avec nous
c'est un homme que tout un pays se fige
au pleurer sa princesse
civile
j'aime ou vieux hommes ou femmes
et policiers
à ce moment enfin sur le palais de la
reine à part des drapeaux en berne et
déclenché une vague d'applaudissements
cela représente le sentiment de tout le
monde aujourd'hui c'est un geste
merveilleux que la reine fait la
pression et puis ces pèlerins
réconcilier avec la monarchie vont
prendre le chemin die parc ici nouveau
transmet sur écran géant la messe à
westminster là bas dans la cathédrale
ils ne sont que 1900 invités alors que
dans cette église à ciel ouvert on
rejoue longchamp le jour du pape avec
une foule bigarrée
il est vrai mais qui elle aussi intègre
les accidentés de la vie
londres longchamp on pourrait s'y
tromper je pense qu'il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui voulaient participer
on voulait montrer notre respect à diana
et c'est difficile de le faire chez soi
si le vente at elle et quand on habite
langues
ce raid est regrettable pour enfin venir
c'est si triste
une seule chose a fait se lever comme un
seul homme
cette poule effondré de chagrin lorsque
le frère du taiana a condamné la presse
à scandale et juré qu'il protégerait a
émis il ya alors une immense émotion
traversa le parc nourrit d'un espoir que
la mort de diana serve de leçon
émotion intense donc la chair de poule à
fleur de peau comment expliquer philippe
harrouard cette vague de ferveur qui a
submergé aujourd'hui le royaume-uni qui
n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom
écoutez c'est difficile à expliquer ce
qui est vrai c'est que certainement
parmi ces millions de personnes y avait
beaucoup de gens que la princesse diana
agaçait de son vivant de part son côté
disons superstar ou bien par sa vie qui
était un peu controversé mais ce qui est
vrai aussi c'est que beaucoup de gens
admiraient sa liberté liberté d'élever
ses enfants vivent liberté vis-à-vis de
l'establishment et puis aussi sa
croisade contre les malheurs du monde
son engagement sincère envers les plus
pauvres
et bien c'est cet aspect que ce soir les
gens retiennent le plus grand nombre
tiens cet aspect c'est d'élire une femme
généreuse et pleine de compassion
même si elle était comme tout le monde
vulnérable et fragile et ce qui est
remarquable c'est que dans cette foule
il y avait non seulement des gens
simples des gens des démunis peut-être
mais il y avait toutes les classes et
toutes les communautés de grande
bretagne unie dans le chagrin et par sa
mort diana a réussi à rassembler toute
une nation qui a parlé d'une seule voix
qui s'est manifestée grandement et bien
peu nombreuses sont les personnalités
qui sont capables aujourd'hui de créer
un tel phénomène
après les cérémonies de ce matin à
londres le convoi funèbre est parti pour
alsop à 120 km au nord de la capitale de
l'angleterre c'est là qu'a été enterrés
diana princesse de galles soute au long
du parcours des milliers des milliers de
personnes ont lancé des fleurs sur la
voiture qui transportait le cercueil
jacques cardoze le quartier des
ministères
l'arche de la garde royale du silence à
la foule
dernier voyage de la princesse de galles
à l'entrée de l'autoroute des centaines
d'automobilistes stoppent leur véhicule
pour voir passer le cortège délices des
roses un tapis de fleurs recouvrait la
bentley témoignages abondent dans le
véhicule s'arrête le chauffeur retire
quelques bouquins
de londres à althorp 120 km plus loin
des centaines de milliers d'admirateurs
ont manifesté leur peine désormais loin
des regards
loin de cette foule la princesse de
galles se reposer en paix
dans le petit village d'alstom ce n'est
pas dans le cimetière ni même dans
l'église que va reposer le corps de la
princesse de galles mais à l'intérieur
de la propriété de l'immense propriété
de ses parents le compte de spencer dix
septième génération du nom au milieu du
lac que vous voyez sur ces images
aériennes il ya une petite île c'est là
qu'a été déposé le cercueil de diana le
petit village d'al khor attendait cet
après midi sa princesse sa fille du pays
qui rentraient finalement pour le repos
éternel dans cette campagne britannique
si tranquille par rapport à la vie
qu'elle avait vécu ces dernières années
valérie fournis ou pascal quint les
habitants du comté sont arrivés à pied
des quatre points cardinaux en famille
progressivement ils ont délaissé la
retransmission télévisée pour voir le
cortège passait de leurs propres yeux
pour saluer une dernière fois
l'enfant du pays elle revient à la
maison chez nous j'habite northampton et
personne ne pourra nous l'enlever
maintenant des mêmes origines qui crée
presque des liens tout le monde a
l'impression de la connaître ici et on
ne réalise pas qu'elle est partie c'est
depuis sa mort on réalise sont
importants ils ont attendu patiemment en
suivant la progression du cortège à la
télévision ou à la radio
en évaluant au fur et à mesure la
distance qui les sépare de diana puis
elle est apparue le cortège a traversé
par le stone le premier village avant al
top hall sous les applaudissements un
bref passage du convoi funéraire
et rares sont ceux qui ont pu cacher
leur émotion
c'était la reine de notre coeur et on
les met tout simplement on a dû marcher
des kilomètres pour être ici et même si
cela n'a duré que quelques secondes
cela en valait la peine j'ai perdu un
membre de ma famille
ils sont partis comme ils sont venus
l'âme peut être un peu moins lourde
maintenant que diana repose au pays sur
leurs terres où ils n'ont pu que fleurir
son passage ce que redoutait avant tout
les habitants d'althorp un petit village
tranquille de 200 âmes à peine c'était
que leurs petites villes deviennent en
fait à un parc d'attractions ça c'était
leur peur suprême valérie fournioux oui
daniel les habitants du village de la
famille de la princesse de galles
craignent l'affût des pèlerins et des
badauds dans les années à venir au moins
aussi dans les années dans les semaines
qui viennent
wilmington ce petit village dont vous
venez de parler est aujourd'hui devenu
un symbole comme arles top hall où diana
était enterrée loin des regards cet
après midi loin de la fureur du monde et
les villageois aimerait également
conservé leur intimité leur tranquillité
mais comme ils ne pourront jamais
empêcher les gens de venir ici
une stèle où une plaque à la mémoire de
diana
sera installé devant un top hall et une
fois par an au jour anniversaire de sa
mort
les grilles du château de la famille des
spencer seront ouvertes pour permettre
au public de se recueillir sur sa tombe
merci valérie ce matin nous vous avons
montré les images officielles et
officieuses de la cérémonie cette foule
immense massée sur le parcours du
cortège officiel
pendant ce temps là il y avait un autre
londres 1 londres déserté une capitale
britannique pratiquement privé de
voitures ce qui est tout de même rare un
samedi matin dans un pays où depuis
longtemps on a oublié le sacro-saint
week-end reportage d' etienne leenhardt
d'ordinaire à 9h le samedi matin dans
les quartiers commerçants de londres les
russes ont déjà plein à craquer
aujourd'hui on enterre diana et toute la
ville semblant porter le deuil
un fan gars quare s'est mise en berne
les pigeons ont déserté et les touristes
sont ailleurs
au quartier général de scotland yard les
autorités contrôlent plus d'un million
de personnes mais cette foule à est
calme il n'y aura guère d'incidents 11
heures
diana rentrer à westminster les autobus
les trains partout à travers le pays
sat une minute de silence dans tous les
parcs de londres ils sont très nombreux
des haut parleurs ils nous ramènent à la
cérémonie
à cet instant londres se figea précédent
indemne d'un silence et semble se
demander pourquoi il est si triste
c'est une princesse qu'on enterrait et
c'est une reine ils ont perdu
après l'émotion il faut tirer une
conclusion politique avec un peu de
recul de cet événement qui a élu
aujourd'hui était née marthe la presse
britannique est d'accord pour dire
qu'avant qu'il ya eu avant la
disparition de diana et qu'il y aura
après que rien ne sera plus comme avant
pour la famille royale je prends daniel
que les images d'aujourd'hui en sont la
preuve
aucun britannique n'aurait jamais
imaginé voir la reine s'avancer à pied
vers la grille de son palais pour
s'incliner respectueusement sur le
cercueil de son ex belle fille aucun
d'entre eux n'aurait sans doute imaginé
voir le prince charles remonter le mall
cet immense avenue qu'il n'avait jamais
sans doute empreintes et qu'en voiture
et puis il ya eu ces phrases très dur du
frère de diana charles spencer pendant
la cérémonie il s'est engagé à continuer
l'éducation de ses neveux william et
harry
à l'image de l'éducation que leur avait
donné sa soeur imaginative at il dit
afin que leurs âmes ne soit pas
engloutie par le devoir et par la
tradition ces mots sont très durs à
l'égard de la famille royale mais la
foule vous l'avez entendu les a
applaudis et la reine s'est peut-être
dit que la semaine finie c'est comme
elle avait commencé dans
l'incompréhension la plus totale
total entre sa famille la famille royale
et le peuple britannique alors charles
saura-t-il bousculer ses traditions et
cette rigidité beaucoup en doutent
le prince william va-t-il prendre la
place de sa mère dans le coeur des
britanniques
ces questions qui nous paraissent
peut-être à nouveau utile les anglais en
attendent des réponses l'émotion de ces
derniers jours la prouver et c'est
peut-être là une victoire une victoire
tragiquement posthume pour la princesse
de galles
merci etienne voilà benoît ce que l'on
pouvait dire sur l'actualité de cette
journée ici à l'ombre ce soir la
princesse de galles lady diana est entré
dans l'histoire sous le titre de
princesse des coeurs niel je vous le
disais en titre l'autre événement de la
journée c'est l'émotion provoquée en
inde par la mort de mère teresa le deuil
national a été décrété et la foule toute
la journée s'est pressée au siège des
missionnaires de la charité à calcutta
marque maisonneuve
ce dont elle s'occupait les plus pauvres
d'entre les pauvres l'avait surnommée la
sainte des bidonvilles le dévouement de
mère teresa leur égard semblait sans
limite sa mort on a fixé le terme
à 87 ans la petite soeur albanaise
incarnait le symbole de la bonté et pas
seulement pour les catholiques
je suis vraiment déprimé et j'ai
vraiment de la peine à cause de la mort
de mère teresa c'était une grande dame
plus qu un pays en deuil
c'est le sous continent indien tout
entier qui pendant deux jours va pleurer
celle qui nourrissait avec son ordre
les missionnaires de la charité cinq
cent mille familles chaque année celle
qui accueillait vingt mille enfants dans
les écoles celle qui soignait 90000
l'épreuve à l'échelle de l'inde
une goutte d'eau 10 et elle mais elle
donner plus à ceux qui l'ont connu et
aux autres elle donnait l'espoir la
possibilité qu'on peut changer les
choses qu'on peut apporter à tous les
niveaux nous sommes un peu de justice à
peu d'amour pour faire de ce monde un
monde meilleur
pourtant elle a aussi affiché des
convictions très controversé
encourageant les militants anti
avortement
moi je le redis n'apportez pas beaucoup
près de votre fonds à l'heure de rendre
des comptes
car même les bons catholiques doivent le
faire le jour de leur mort mère teresa
avait déjà imaginer ce qui allait se
passer
confessions sur la télévision du vatican
avec le cardinal laghi quand vous serez
devant saint pierre que vous dira t-il
il me reconnaîtra saint-pierre alignera
les cinquante mille morts que je lui ai
envoyé avec le billet d'entrée au
paradis ce sera magnifique sur d'une vie
après la mort mais reza montre que rien
ne compte
si ce n'est l'espérance l'hommage ce
soir est unanime le pape dont elle était
très proche a célébré une messe à sa
mémoire avant d'adresser un message à
l'ordre qu'elle a créée les obsèques de
mère teresa ont lieu le 13 septembre sur
place la mannschaft
troubé jean paul ii rendez ce matin
visite aux blessés de la vie réunit près
de castel gandolfo par l'association des
volontaires de la souffrance
oui l'occasion était toute trouvée pour
un hommage à mère teresa que le pape
avait déjà honoré ce matin par une messe
privée
mère teresa a marqué l'histoire de notre
siècle
elle a défendu avec courage la vie elle
a suivi les êtres humains prônant
toujours la dignité et le respect
pendant ce temps au coeur de rome dans
un des quartiers les plus tranquilles et
sereins de la capitale la maison des
soeurs de la charité dire cuillé dans le
silence et la prière
mon sentiment il n'est pas possible
d'exprimer ici nous ne souhaitons pas
faire de publicité pour nous maintenant
il y à la prière
et c'est cela l'important nous sommes
avec notre mère dans la prière et dans
l'espérance
notre mère n'est pas morte pour nous et
déjà ici à rome
certains parient sur une prompte
béatification la reçoit de la petites
soeurs des pauvres de calcutta
parmi les personnes qui l'ont très bien
connu il y à jacqueline de decker mr
thérèse alice d'elle que c'était son
double les deux femmes s'étaient
rencontrées à calcutta jacqueline de
decker infirmières il soignait alors les
pauvres frédéric dupuy et patrick
wuersten l'on rencontrait à anvers où
elle a pris sa retraite
jacqueline de decker est infirmière
depuis deux ans elle s'occupe des
pauvres à calcutta
lorsqu'on lui présente sur térésa
c'était en 1949
on m'a dit non mais tu devrais voir une
seule est sorti de son couvent et elle
voudrait commencer le travail comme toi
tu fais depuis deux ans s'occuper des
pauvres êtres pour vivent avec les
pauvres
je suis entre la chapelle gêné vu de dos
c'est comme ça que l'élu au début son
dos et elle qui priaient elle voulait
déjà aider les pauvres à sa manière
simplement elle a commencé là disent ça
peut pas faire les amants étaient dans
la rue et la première chose que j'ai
trouvé c'est un petit enfant qui étaient
dans la rigole et qui avait lieu de
mourir je les prie les laver je les
soigne et très vite jacqueline de decker
doit rentrer précipitamment à anvers
pour être soigné et ne pourra plus aider
mère teresa pourtant toutes ces années
elle sera présente à ses côtés en
prières aujourd'hui celle que mère
teresa considérée comme une part
d'elle-même ne ressent aucune tristesse
lacroix je suis heureuse pour elle j'ai
tout de suite vu un pour une joie
intérieure de savoir quelle était enfin
ali 10 elle n'y a pas de danger
à 84 ans et malgré la maladie jacqueline
de decker continue sa correspondance
avec les soeurs de calcutta
toujours dans la pauvreté mais riche de
ses souvenirs
une autre personne l'a bien connu c'est
soeur emmanuelle elle l'avait rencontré
au caire quand elle s'occupait de ces
chiffonniers olivier théron et est allé
lui rendre visite dans le var elle
évoque le souvenir de mère teresa mais
vous allez le voir elle le fait au
présent j'allais beaucoup plus vous chez
les regarde et j'ai chanté que dans
cette somme quelque chose c'est à dire
que et elle transpire elle transpire
pour m'expliquer là elle est fragile
à travers ce sport c'était déjà assez
sujet est bien quelque chose qui émanait
et on avait envie on la regarde on se
dit je vais travailler davantage cette
femme chez de l'effort gérable doit
aussi aller jusqu'au bout on peut tu
râles et plus voilà donc le message mois
qu'elle m'a donné j'ai bien dit d'eux
qu'ils ont ressentie de la même manière
chez vap le mans va au-delà fatick toile
par un peu plus koba important
je sais que je peux dire que chaque
peuple poursuit elle c'était dans les
bas mot justement il ya des moments aux
yeux ou ce qu'est ce que je vais pas
pouvoir m'arrêter
non tu t'arrêtes pas panneaux non plus à
travers le monde chez chat
je crois que l c'est un détonateur des
forces et à détonateur d'amour avec
l'acteur de joie elle est toujours elle
veut toujours de la joie j'ai été très
frappée amour force et joie et puis
naturellement les radiations de l'amour
du trousses une horloge ça s'appelait la
peau est de nouveau sur emmanuel un
nouveau massacre en algérie 40 à 80
villageois ont été tués dans le village
de beni messous à seulement dix
kilomètres d'alger selon les autorités
les meurtriers des islamistes présumés
se seraient cachés dans les bois
environnants avant d'attaquer le village
en pleine nuit
la plupart des victimes ont été égorgées
il y aurait de mon blog de nombreux
blessés
nous n'avons pour l'instant aucune image
sur ce nouveau drame qui intervient
alors que des accrochages se seraient
produits entre les forces de sécurité et
des islamistes de la région de blida
faisant une trentaine de morts
la visite de jacques chirac en
mauritanie le président français s'est
rendu dans le désert mauritanien
aujourd'hui pour y annoncer une aide
française sur l'alimentation en eau des
quartiers défavorisés de la capitale
nouakchott sur place véronique sat olive
et jean corps du dans la chaleur torride
des chants et des cris de joie
ils sont venus par milliers du désert
dans ce pays parmi les plus pauvres du
monde
l' enthousiasme c'est le plus beau des
cadeaux pour honorer son nom de jacques
chirac avait promis il ya des années
qu'ils viendraient la mauritanie
l'accueil avec ses milliers de chameau
et tout le folklore de l'amitié ou si le
président de la république est venu
affirmer que la france ne jouera plus
les gendarmes en afrique c'est un
nouveau partenariat qui s'organise
autour d'être concrète au développement
économique
un discours que pierre messmer ancien
premier ministre ancien gouverneur de
mauritanie à preuve de parvenir à créer
ensemble une chaîne de solidarité de
connaissance mutuelle d'ambition
partagée défi qui consiste à ne pas
accepter ni normand nation ni à
l'échelle de la planète
le citoyen ou de pays qu'ils soient
marginalisés par l'histoire
jacques chirac a confirmé ici
l'adaptation de la politique africaine
de la france que les socialistes soient
est également la france continuera de
soutenir et d'accompagner le
développement économique de ce continent
mais le temps de la gérance militaire
est terminée c'est une page qui tourne
l'actualité politique en france ce sont
les journées parlementaires de l'udf
apport d'albert dans les landes et la
position très offensive de françois
léotard qui s'interrogent sur les
capacités d'homme d'état de lionel
jospin le reportage de jean baptiste
auprès d'ali et bernie mériaux françois
léotard et françois bayrou sont d'accord
sur une chose ils sont dans l'opposition
alors aujourd'hui ils en ont tiré les
premières conclusions devant les
parlementaires de l'udf nous soyons le
parti d embarrasser grise des
mélancolies il ne s'agit pas seulement
de faire bonne figure à l'udf
on a évoqué les raisons de la défausse
aux dernières législatives mais entre
soi en aparté en public
la stratégie de la rentrée simple fait
feu sur le gouvernement
je suis pour ma part très sceptique sur
les capacités de monsieur jospin à être
véritablement un homme d'état c'est à
dire faisant passer avant ses propres
intérêts partisans
l'intérêt de la communauté nationale et
je dirais que depuis trois mois d'une
certaine manière
nos pires inquiétudes sont en train de
se réaliser en deux laferrère france au
plan aubry le ton est à la critique l'
avantage c'est de ne pas parler des
équilibres internes à l'udf toujours
délicat françois léotard et françois
bayrou ont préféré afficher leur entente
et leur propre projet d'ailleurs pas une
fois ils n'ont cité jacques chirac
en corse la trêve semble terminée un
commando de cinq hommes cagoulés a
attaqué une gendarmerie au sud d'ajaccio
les deux gendarmes s'y trouvait en
ont été pris en otage et neutralisée le
temps de faire sauter la gendarmerie
l'attentât a été revendiqué par le flnc
qui s'attribue également l'explosion qui
a endommagé jeudi les bâtiments de l'ena
l'école nationale d'admistration à
strasbourg qui est d'ailleurs maintenant
placé sous surveillance puis en espagne
le thé à vient peut-être de commettre
son premier assassinat depuis la mort du
conseiller municipal miguel angel blanco
le taa tué un policier près de bilbao
remplaçants album sous sa voiture
le sport maintenant avec d'abord la très
belle entrée en matière de l'aviron
français aux championnats du monde trois
bateaux en finale et trois médailles
dont une d'or pour le deux sans barreur
les épreuves ont eu lieu à recques
belette en savoie les copains d'abord
sur la grand mare des canards c'est
toute l'équipe de france qui se met à
l'eau pour féliciter jean christophe
rolland et michel andrieu c'est aux
quinze 100 m que les deux français ont
fourni leurs efforts pour terminer avec
4 secondes d'avancé sur leurs
poursuivants un titre mondial c'est la
consécration pour cette paire médaillé
de bronze à atlanta qui s'est formé il
ya déjà six ans et dont on annonçait la
prochaine séparation après cette
médaille d'or
ce deux sans barreur pourrait prolonger
jusqu'à sydney dans leur sillage ils ont
emmené le quatre sans barreur tricolore
mons l'évêque timbaut ce qu'est faucher
et empoché la médaille d'argent loin
derrière c'est vrai les anglais qui
portait aujourd'hui un crêpe noir en
hommage à la princesse diana leur
capitaine emblématique great grève ainsi
obtenu son 6e titre mondial
enfin il ya la grenobloise bénédicte
luzuy quasiment à domicile sur ce lac
d'aiguebelette qui a obtenu la médaille
d'argent du stif poids légers et bras
tricolore levé sur un podium
donc on va s'y prendre goût six bateaux
seront en finale demain
le dernier représentant d'une lignée de
très grands chefs d'orchestre soeur
georg solti est mort hier à antibes
il avait 84 ans guerre au sol qui était
né à budapest
mais la guerre l'avait amené à quitter
son pays on l'écouté si diriger
l'orchestré philharmonique de chicago
dans un extrait de thé lot de vertige
non
et
c'est parce que la fin de ce journal
dans un instant la météo de nathalie
rihouet le dernier journal ce sera vers
vers 16h15
florence duprat n'oubliez pas demain la
reprise de polémiques l'émission de
michèle cotta qui reviendra sur les
obsèques de lady diana et sur le débat
de la rentrée en france sur les
privatisations
je vous retrouverai demain 13h bonne
soirée sur france 2
le buy-in jo
mais hugh grant loin de brûler les
touches ouais vous pourquoi
dubaï d'où je la sors
je me souviens match monde news
ainsi
alors
on ne refait pas
faux
de plus
oui
moi quand j'étais petite j'adorais les
films de gladiateurs et s'inquiétait
d'ailleurs un petit peu mes parents dont
là normalement il devait y avoir de la
boxe mais ils ont mis michel boujenah ça
me range plutôt à la star d'hollywood à
un wannabe l'afp haye d'emploi de vue
psychiatrique nous pouvons distinguer
deux sortes d'individus dangereux pour
la société
le psychopathe et le psychotique lui ce
psychopathe et lui le psychotique le
pied cocotte le psychotique psychopathe
j'écoute dimanche soir sur france 2 ce
qui est le plus dangereux le tueur en
série
hier à auteuil après plus d'un an et
demi d'absence c'était la rentrée
d'olivier mescam l'un de nos plus grands
jockeys d'obstacle le 31 décembre 1995
lors d'une chute en course il se
fracture le tibia et le péroné un
accident banal dans le métier mais qui
d'opérations en complications va se
transformer en un long cauchemar
c'est finalement en août dernier que
didier mescam a pu reprendre
l'entraînement
à 39 ans son courage force l'admiration
de la profession car son retour sur les
hippodromes était un challenge auquel
bien peu croyaient
j'ai toujours dit que je reviendrai je
serai un jour par emma plat et sa place
est parmi les meilleurs didier mescam
est de nouveau en selle il n'est pas un
obstacle presse et voici les rapports du
tiercé quarté + quinté plus et 2 sur 4
disputé cet après-midi sur l'hippodrome
de vincennes
la rougeole les oreillons et la rubéole
ne sont pas des maladies bénignes
oran très difficile en ce moment il y
aller 20 jours plus simple cette année
vingt jours pour découvrir tous les
crédits qui facilite la rentrée appelé
c'était l'amour au 0 800 116 116
oh
bonjour à tous l'anticyclone est là sur
l'atlantique et il guette le moment où
il va pouvoir réinstaller ces autres
pression sur notre pays ce sera chose
faite à partir de lundi avec le retour
d'un temps très ensoleillé un peu
partout en france
encore faut-il se débarrasser de ce
front qui n'en finit plus d'onduler sur
notre pays alors il est en train de se
décaler vers le sud est et dans les
heures à venir vous avez constaté il va
perdre de son activité il va se
désagréger au contact des autres
pression le problème c'est que comme
nous sommes en flux de nord-ouest et
bien un nouveau front arrive à partir de
demain
il vient décosse et dès demain matin on
va le retrouver sur les côtes de la
manche et sur nord-bretagne avec
peut-être quelques bruines au nord de la
seine à l'avant un ciel variable
localement de belles éclaircies des pays
de loire jusqu'à la champagne ardenne
une tranche de ciel bien dégagé des pays
d du bordelais jusqu'au nord-est
attention cependant à la présence de
brume de brouillard le matin dans
certaines vallées et un temps qui
restera très gries c'est notre front qui
va s'étendre du sud ouest jusqu'aux
alpes autour de la méditerranée pas de
problème le ciel sera bien dégagé
avec des températures qui au lever du
jour varieront entre 8 et 13 degrés sur
la moitié nord 12 à 19 degrés sur la
moitié sud
l'évolution du temps pour l'après midi
avec la grisaille qui s'installe sur
toute la moitié nord du pays
localement de timides éclaircies vont
revenir une évolution orageuse sur les
pyrénées et sur les alpes ailleurs du
soleil et des températures en légère
hausse comprise entre 19 et 21 degrés au
nord 22 à 28 degrés au sud voici l'essai
mairie de nous serons demain le dimanche
7 septembre nous fêterons les rênes le
soleil va se lever à 7h17 pour se
coucher à 20h19 excellent soirée
s'offrant deux jours trouve demain soir
demain matin dans thé ou café ce sera
patrice drevet merci bonsoir et à demain
bonsoir bienvenue au second tirage du
loto thé centaine d'ici septembre 1997
le 25
le 43
le 3
le 30 sept
le 41
le 2
numéro complémentaire le 16 pour ce
second tirage du loto les numéros
gagnants sont 25 43 3 37 41 2 et le 16
n'oubliez pas mercredi prochain super
cagnotte de 30 millions de francs
minimum très bien
qui
filles
après le journal de la nuit l'âge d'or
d'hollywood avant d'aller vous trichez
on vous fait visiter l'industrie du rêve
payet d'emploi de vue psychiatrique ne
pouvons distinguer deux sortes
d'individus dangereux pour la société
le psychopathe et le psychotique lui
c'est le psychopathe et lui le
psychotique le petit come back le
psychotique psychopathe
j'écoute dimanche soir sur france 2 ce
qui met le plus d'argent
le tourneur en série
et n'oublie oblige montantes ou sans
talent sur vos écrans avec les éditions
atlas la collection de ses plus grands
fils est clair un acteur percutant with
me battre avec moi qui ne cache pas ses
sentiments finir chez votre marchand de
journaux ses plus grands films en ville
et où il y à vivre mon temps cette
semaine le numéro deux césar et rosalie
la vidéo et son livret 39 francs 39
francs quelques allant chez swann au
moins les portes sont ouvertes
profitez-en pour découvrir la nouvelle
citroën xsara et la gamme saxo à partir
de 50 milles 900 francs
avec moins du monde les éditions atlas
ont rapporté pour vous des billets des
pièces authentiques des quatre coins du
monde
est-ce qu 12 du mozambique de vrais
billets
ils me feraient pièce mais aux ados du
brésil et du monde la collection pour
voyager au coeur des monnaies cette
semaine le numéro un le biais de stentys
du pérou la pièce de 1 cent deux
amériques et le fascicule 5 francs plus
qu'une collection c'est un trésor un
numéro de téléphone sans nom ni adresse
pour découvrir qui se cache derrière
taper 36-17 à nu annuaire inversé par
minitel
aujourd'hui c'est nouveau je vais vous
parler de tout l'univers multimédia avec
sa collection de cd rom et de façon tous
les univers multimédia interactif pour
apprendre et progresser en nous amusant
c'est la préhistoire à l'espace tout
devient plus vivant et passionnant
question qui va offrir tout l'univers
multimédia à ses enfants
le premier cd rom et son fascicule 49
francs seulement chez votre marchand de
journaux
avec un classeur en cadeau et si vous
donniez à vos yeux la télé de vos rêves
canalsat et
de la partie heures avec arrêt kart 7
matches de d1 chaque journée de
championnat
du jamais vu avec la f1 sur sept canaux
et bien sur eurosport tous les regards
sur l'actualité avec quatre chaînes info
en exclusivité satellite disney channel
et chaque jour du spectacle avec 20
grands films sur quatre chaînes cinéma
qui peut vous proposer 40 chaînes et
services d'exception
canal satellite le meilleur du numérique
les paraboles et gratuit pour tout
nouvel abonnement d'un an à canal
satellite
c'est vrai que c'est par ici
à moi une bonne ambiance j'ai
quelquefois vraiment peur de ne plus
être à la hauteur
si c'est ce que j'ai envie de
beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes pour me
dire que c'est dégueulasse non plus que
la violence qui leur est étiqueté comme
aussi de convent faire pour une
collection jacques cotta et pascal
martin décode les secrets de notre
société par la petite porte
rentré dimanche soir dans le secret des
lycées
madame monsieur bonsoir lady diana a
rejoint sa légende
la princesse de galles repose désormais
sur une île à l'abri des regards au
coeur du domaine familial d'althorp
samedi matin c'est avec beaucoup
d'émotion une grande dignité que les
britanniques ont rendu un dernier
hommage à leur princesse à défaut d'être
royale les obsèques de lady diana ont
été grandioses william irigoyen 2
millions de personnes peut être plus
pour rendre un ultime hommage celle que
les britanniques après leur reine de
coeur après son hommage télévisé d'hier
à lady diana
la reine a quitté buckingham palace pour
s'incliner devant le cercueil enveloppé
de l'étendard roya un geste remarquée
après la polémique sur le silence de la
famille royale et son retrait dans la
demeure écossaise de balmoral oubliant
le protocole le prince charles ses deux
enfants william et harry
le duc d'edimbourg ainsi que le frère de
diana ont ensuite accompagné le cercueil
dans l'abbaye de westminster pendant ce
temps mis pour la première fois le
drapeau britannique été mis en berne sur
le toit de buckingham palace
le bail jours
mais yu
gr
le bail au monde
vous
ainsi que la douleur
on ne refait pas
debout
elle n'a jamais compris pourquoi ces
authentiques bonnes intentions étaient
tournés en dérision par les médias
pourquoi ils semblaient chercher sa
merde en permanence à tarbes
c'est effarant ma seule et unique
explication est que l'otan d'une bonté
est considérée comme une menace à
l'extrémité opposée du spectre moral
nous respectons pleinement l'héritage
dans lequel tu es enfants sont nés et
nous respecteront toujours leur rôle
royal nous les y encourage on
le corps de lady diana a ensuite été
emportées à althorp parc au manoir
familial des spencer pour y être inhumée
au passage du convoi mortuaire
ils ont été des milliers à lancer des
fleurs pour accompagner l'ultime voyage
de la rose l'angleterre après les
obsèques de la princesse de galles la
foule a tenu à rendre hommage aussi à
l'audience ayed les dizaines d'anonymes
se sont rendus sur cette terre au
cimetière de gros coup d'arrêt aux kings
ils ont déposé des fleurs et sony les
registres de condoléances nous dit al
fayed avait trouvé la mort aux côtés de
la princesse dimanche dernier un
accident de voiture à paris
beaucoup d'émotions en inde aussi après
la mort de mère teresa le gouvernement
indien a décrété un deuil national et
décidé de lui organiser des obsèques
d'état obsèques auront lieu le 13
septembre
les hommages continuent d'affluer du
monde entier et à kehl cutter on se
presse au siège des missionnaires de la
charité pour saluer sa mémoire
marc maisonneuve ce dont elle s'occupait
les plus pauvres d'entre les pauvres
l'avait surnommée la sainte des
bidonvilles le dévouement de mère teresa
leur égard semblait sans limite sa mort
on a fixé le terme
à 87 ans la petite soeur albanaise
incarnait le symbole de la bonté et pas
seulement pour les catholiques
je suis vraiment déprimé j'ai vraiment
de la peine à cause de la mort de mère
teresa c'était une grande dame
plus qu un pays en deuil
c'est le sous continent indien tout
entier qui pendant deux jours va pleurer
celle qui nourrissait avec son ordre
les missionnaires de la charité cinq
cent mille familles chaque année celle
qui accueillait vingt mille enfants dans
les écoles celle qui soignait 90000
l'épreuve mais elle donnait plus à ceux
qui l'ont connu et aux autres elle
donnait l'espoir à l'heure de rendre des
comptes car même les bons catholiques
doivent le faire le jour de leur mort
mère teresa avait déjà imaginer ce qui
allait se passer
confessions sur la télévision du vatican
avec le cardinal laghi quand vous serez
devant saint pierre que vous dira t-il
il me reconnaîtra saint-pierre alignera
les cinquante mille morts que je lui ai
envoyé avec le billet d'entrée au
paradis ce sera magnifique sur d'une vie
après la mort mais repérer sa montre que
rien ne compte
si ce n'est l'espérance la violence
continue en algérie 63 personnes ont été
tuées dans le village de beni messous à
seulement 10 km d'alger les meurtriers
des islamistes présumés se seraient
cachés dans les bois avant d'attaquer
les villageois en pleine nuit
le bilan de ce carnage est encore
provisoire mais il y aurait également de
nombreux blessés
jamais un tel massacre on avait été
perpétrée aussi près de la capitale
algérienne politique trois mois après la
défaite aux législatives du df à
clôturer ces journées parlementaires à
port d'albret dans les landes
l'occasion pour françois léotard de
critiquer le gouvernement en place jean
baptiste près d'aller françois léotard
et françois bayrou sont d'accord sur une
chose ils sont dans l'opposition
alors aujourd'hui ils en ont tiré les
premières conclusions devant les
parlementaires de l'udf nous soyons le
parti des des mines embarrassé grise des
mélancolies il ne s'agit pas seulement
de faire bonne figure
à l'udf on a évoqué les raisons de la
défaite aux dernières législatives
mais entre soi en aparté en public la
stratégie de la rentrée simple fait feu
sur le gouvernement
je suis pour ma part très sceptique sur
les capacités de monsieur jospin à être
véritablement un homme d'état c'est à
dire faisant passer avant ses propres
intérêts partisans
l'intérêt de la communauté nationale et
je dirais que depuis trois mois d'une
certaine manière nos pires inquiétudes
sont en train de se réaliser en deux
laferrère france au plan aubry le ton
est à la critique l' avantage c'est de
ne pas parler des équilibres internes à
l'udf toujours délicat françois léotard
et françois bayrou ont préféré afficher
leur entente et leur propre projet
d'ailleurs pas une fois ils n'ont cité
jacques chirat encore sa trêve semble
compromise gendarmerie au sud d'ajaccio
a été plastiquée par un commando de cinq
hommes
auparavant il en prend en otage les deux
gendarmes qui revenait d'une patrouille
de routine avant lui relâcher
l'attentât a été revendiqué par un
correspondant se réclamant du flnc
le cnt a par ailleurs reconnu être
l'auteur de l'explosion qui a endommagé
les locaux de l'école nationale
d'administration à strasbourg sport aux
championnats du monde d'aviron avec
belette en savoie les français se sont
distingués michel andrieu et jean
christophe rolland ont décroché l'or
pour le deux sans barreur et ce n'est
peut-être pas fini car trois bateaux
français sont en finale elle la voix
les copains d'abord sur la grand mare
des canards c'est toute l'équipe de
france qui se met à l'eau pour féliciter
jean christophe rolland et michel
andrieu 7 au 15 100 m que les deux
français ont fourni leurs efforts pour
terminer avec 4 secondes d'avancé sur
leurs poursuivants un titre mondial
c'est la consécration pour cette paire
médaillé de bronze à atlanta qui s'est
formé il ya déjà six ans et dont on
annonçait la prochaine séparation après
cette médaille d'or
ce deux sans barreur pourrait prolonger
jusqu'à 6 mai dans leur sillage ils ont
emmené le quatre sans barreur tricolore
mons les vecteurs bosquet est fauché ont
empoché la médaille d'argent loin
derrière c'est vrai les anglais qui
portait aujourd'hui un crêpe noir en
hommage à la princesse diana leur
capitaine emblématique des reds grève
ainsi obtenu son 6e titre mondial
enfin il ya la grenobloise bénédicte
luzuy quasiment à domicile sur ce lac
d'aiguebelette qui a obtenu la médaille
d'argent du stif poids légers les bras
tricolore levé sur un podium
on pourrait y prendre goût six bateaux
seront en finale demain et en tennis on
apprend à l'instant que l'australien
patrick rafter tête de série numéro 13 a
rejoint le britannique greg oz ce qui au
final de l'us open de tennis en battant
l'américain michael chang 6 3 6 3 6 4
samedi à flushing meadow certains
l'avaient surnommée la baguette la plus
rapide de l'ouest il était sans conteste
le dernier représentant d'une lignée de
très grands chefs d'orchestre soeur
georg solti est décédé vendredi soir à
antibes à l'âge de 84 ans d'origine
hongroise il avait quitté budapest sa
ville natale durant la deuxième guerre
mondiale l'écoutons ici dirigé
l'orchestré philharmonique de chicago
dans un extrait d'hôtels ou de vertige
vivant
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
d'avoir suivi dans quelques instants les
prévisions météo de nathalie rihouet je
vous donne rendez vous demain aux
alentours de 23h 50 passé une très bonne
nuit